hmm
if you are watching this just know if
you see this movie you are an accessory
to a crime
[Music]
my name is Rick klingman I am an
attorney and a political consultant some
people might say oh that guy is a con
artist I know you guys or a fraud or a
dirty trickster or he can't name all
three branches of government
[Music]
and they're wrong I am simply a truth
provider
[Music]
every once in a while someone will hire
me to get their truth out there
Antonio Kelly
is running for congress right here in
Los Angeles oh yes and I have evidence
that he may be a demon
it might be hard to prove if it's true
that's a big deal but I think yeah you
can do a little uh digging on this guy
you're looking for dirt on Antonio I
need Simon I'm in he led the boycott of
Chipotle when they started serving
soyrizo
you expose you exploit he's got a sex
tape
look at that naughty boy that's
that's his face grab my dick and snapped
it back
he's hiding something and we're gonna
find it
there are other ways to make a living
you guys are idiots I'm a lawyer I'll
see you in court
the more I think about it and talk about
it I start to believe their truth
then it becomes the truth
at this point we would like to open it
up to any questions you might have yeah
yeah oh what was that